When you're dealing with cancer, there is always a reason why.
There's always a reason why.
And the reason why stems from almost always the cause of the
step-done replication cycle.
Apoptosis can be broken in all of us.
And that is a piece of it.
Yes, it is.
Especially when you're dealing with bad hormones, bad estrogens,
you could say, that you received from the environment,
from plastics, and that women received by taking estrogen therapy,
and things like that.
Your body makes bad estrogens.
Those are specifically apoptotic receptor blockers.
They block what's called the anal receptor, which is an apoptotic receptor,
and it just shuts down apoptosis.
So the cells can't die.
And most commonly, beyondest, each pylori is a big one.
Old vaccines are a huge one.
That's what a huge reason why I'm totally against flu shots and vaccinations.
Each pylori is very common, and old vaccines are very common.
In fact, I had a patient bring a book into me the other day,
because what he tested positive for was the sulc polio virus,
was the cause of his cancer.
He said, did you ever read Dr. Mary's monkey virus?
And I think I've read every book out there, except that one.
So he brought that in, and read that one,
and I'll give you a confidence in our government.
But how the monkey virus was tested for to create cancer,
and enough getting distributed in the polio vaccines in the 60s and 70s.
Not on purpose, per se, at least by the scientists not on purpose,
because actually this Dr. Mary was going to try to expose it,
and she died suddenly.